i've been saying this for a long time
which is anybody who could figure out
how to employ the stay-at-home mom
workforce
is going to make billions of dollars so
if you just work backwards from there's
a bunch of moms at home
they want to earn a little extra income
doesn't have to be a ton
they want to maintain flexibility of
being able to stay at home and work not
like necessarily a fixed number of
full-time hours or the same hours every
day who can solve that problem and um
there's only one example that i know of
that's solving that problem i don't know
if you know any
um for moms yeah
uh maybe uservoice.com i think they do
it uh testing usertesting.com that's the
one i was thinking about oh is it really
my mom my mom worked for them yeah so oh
my god that's so funny i knew about it
what a random thing that we both knew
that um
so i would say so use testing.com
amazing company by the way so you just
pay someone to like go through your
website public by the way um
how cool is this they just went public
and my mom stuck and my mom was like
well say what it is
so user testing basically it's a service
where i have an app or a website i want
to know
where it's confusing for users like
design makes sense to me but like sure
enough when somebody else is using it
they're confused they can't find the
thing they want and they just record
your mom like scrolling through the site
so they have an army of testers which is
just all the requirement is be a normal
person you have
we do not even want you to be highly
skilled like you're supposed to
represent the average customer so they
have a bunch of people they send them a
little camera that um that records their
finger on their phone basically it
records them like and they just talk out
loud so that you give a task you say
like you know find a christmas gift for
your dad and put it into your cart and
they're like okay i'm looking for the
gifts for dad section i don't see it uh
scrolling scrolling scrolling they don't
see the button that says menu oh there's
the menu uh
dad oh it's men's men's okay i'll click
men's um
yeah i don't get how this is sorted oh
this is by new release and you just talk
through what's confusing to you and that
15-minute video goes to the company and
the company gets to watch it and they
get to share it internally their their
researcher basically shares it with the
designer or the engineer they pay like
300 for it right
no no each test is like 25 or 30 dollars
and then um
and then well now it's all switched to
subscription but originally it was like
25 30 a test the tester gets 10 bucks
for doing the test and the company kept
you know 15 20 bucks and so the tester
is like cool i could do like four of
these in an hour
and so a like a bid would come online oh
chipotle wants you to test their new
mobile menu and you would just have to
go quickly say yes and then you qualify
they're looking for women
you know age 40 to 55 in the us and
you're like yeah great i qualify i can
take this test that's a billion dollar
company now it's market cap is over a
billion dollars did your mom get paid
did they give her shares yeah it's
awesome so basically my mom was she
first started off as a tester then she
got hired by the company to review the
other testers because you have to do
quality control so she became like she
would watch the test and give feedback
to the testers like hey
your audio sucks or like you're mumbling
or like
you didn't follow the instructions of
the test um one more strike and you're
out of the testing pool and so that was
her job and she was the oldest person in
the company i think so she was like my
mom's like 63 now so she just retired
this this year so she was there at 62
years old
my mom like had slack and like knew how
to use all like jira she knew what a
jira ticket was like it was crazy my mom
like who knew
and
she got some shares and she had always
told me like should i i was like yeah
you want the shares for sure um and then
she would tell me like
hey the ceo did an all hands he said
this this this is that good i'm like
yeah it sounds good like this company's
doing well i should have bought
secondary stock in the company during
that time because i had like basically
inside info of like this company is
pretty good it's a good quality company
and i was a user of the service as well
so it goes public the other day like
like two weeks ago
and i'm like mom how many shares do you
have and she goes looks in carter she
tells you to share i'm like mom you made
a hundred fifty thousand dollars no way
and she's like yeah because her strike
price was super low uh she was there for
like four or five years and uh so i was
like that's amazing that's like uh like
that's that my mom was so happy yeah
like good for her that's badass
and so like this is why i think this
model of who do you want to pull is
actually interesting because
it's actually
there it's two for two reasons it's
motivating so like the fact that like
they are employing uh most like i have
no idea i should make this up if it's
like mostly women who stayed at home for
a long time and now they want to get
back to it that's like incredibly
motivating it's like look we're serving
our employees yeah it's very noble it's
cool let's say you want to hire uh uh
ex-cons or something it's like look this
is interesting or we're gonna hire a
bunch of 16 year olds and it's going to
be the first job we're going to train
them how to be
men and women and prepare them for the
rest of their lives it's actually
incredibly cool it's fascinating there's
one um i want to look up the name give
him a shout out here so it's higher you
hire military
wives as eas that's awesome it's called
and it also helps with expectations so
you know what you're wearing
you what's it called squared away
squared away that's basically a woman i
think i think her story is that she
i'm assuming
she was in this position i don't really
know um but basically it's military
spouses um
and i was like this is a great this is a
great idea um because you know this is
us uh these are us employees they want
this work they um you know they it's
great to provide for their family while
the husband's away i think it's awesome
and um
and it's it it helps significantly with
expectations because then user testing
knows all right we're mostly going to be
hiring 60 year old or 50 year old uh
women who don't have a probably a ton of
experience with slack and jira
jail we know like here's where they're
gonna struggle here's we're not gonna
show so that's cool